[Music]
no and welcome to this video in this
video we will be examining some simple
games to illustrate the middle game and
sometimes even endgame ideas that can
arise from the nimzo-indian and Rico's
and based repertoire against 1d for that
we come on chesil here written by daniel
bearish and me now let's have a look at
some games we will be looking at twelve
games in total and we'll be starting
with the game in the rico's and defense
to the Queen's Gambit the first game is
played between two grandmasters teamwork
array event Georgie cannot pronounce
that name as surely that's probably
wrong I'm a German in English I to be a
Georgian name it's very difficult so
let's get to actual chess moves we
reached the Rogozin via our usual move
order yeah Bishop before as a starting
point of the rogozin a Korea place to
move Bishop g5 one of them main replies
and him black answers with castling this
move is not what we recommend actually
it's not a terrible move but we
recommend to play aged six immediately
because this gives a white the
opportunity play mistake with bishop
aged for at least an inaccurate move as
this who can be punished with taking now
g5 becomes real possibility an important
resource against a move like before
after which g5 will almost win the game
castles is possible but it's not as
precise III h6 and here in this
particular moment white could have
played Bishop H for which here is a bit
ya better in comparison s g5 is less of
an option with the King already on g8 so
blacks move order here is a bit
different to the one that we choose
after the capture however which has
opposed to a line that we examine of
course in the main theoretical section
rook c1 White's may move and here um
yeah the black player tried to avoid
saying that him let's say Georgie
yeah decides to capture and place if I
this is also what we recommend white
castles and now black takes on deformed
here white has a basic choice between
recapturing on d4 with the pawn and this
is usually not done right away but
rather started with 94s in the game one
simply recapture with the night yeah
this is the main line of the theoretical
section like equalizes with the Bishop
d7 96 idea um not much to worry him in
this game
94 has played so white against a temple
on the Queen winter at five going for an
active post of the Queen not back to e7
nitrogen three the Queen goes to a5 has
some choice them and now white takes on
deformed here and black has a rather
important choice he can play the move
96 as in the game or the move Rock d8 in
the theoretical section we recommend the
multi-age the reasoning is that it
should be yeah there should be higher
priority to play this move putting some
pressure on before and also freeing up
or this maneuver the bishop quite often
has a useful role only aid in particular
after White has pushed the move d5 in
order to open up the position we will
see later that black does not manage to
play the move Bishop to aide
so let's have a look how the game went
96 we need to and now black should I
think play with the AIDS and transpose
to the kind of position that we examined
in the theoretical part now black played
Bishop d7 a3 and here black has a choice
go to d6 or go to e7 it seems that in
this particular case the move Bishop d6
was a bit more precise this is not
really all that relevant theoretically
because black has already deviated from
our main recommendation but the game is
so useful to study because we will see
some typical important motives
so Bishop e7 is plate and now rook e1
this is a very standard kind of move
white is increasing the pressure in the
center and gets move d4 d5 on the map
this is a typical breakthrough if you
have the isolated creep on the IQ people
you usually want to get this idea d4 d5
in the picture opening up the position
and at the same time getting rid of your
weakness this is very important there
the pawn can be a long-term witness you
get rid of it by pushing me 5 and you
open up the position here in particular
the diagonal was White's King this is
the main point him black has to be quite
circumspect iam trying to be ready for
this pawn push what black plate looks
perfectly reasonable he played the move
Rock F to e 8 but it turns out that this
actually has a tactical flaw um the move
rook 88 would have been a bit better
and the main reason is that this would
have been yeah this would have prevented
the next move that happens after rook F
e8 and this is why this game is
interesting now White had the
opportunity to gain a bit of an
advantage by pushing the most B form
this is not at least in my mind a very
easy move lane you can simply ignore it
and doesn't get on your on your agenda
at all because it looks like it just
blunders the pawn and the thing is if
black takes the pawn it will be under
huge pressure after b5 we see that the
knight has very little options there
there are no really good squares you
want to go to the 8th
yeah that looks bad so the relatively
best movie is Knight a5 and after that
bouquet 1 Queen to b4 and Bishop d3
leads to a position that is extremely
difficult for black to handle he has to
still worry about this offside piece and
quite simply as many pieces in the
attack if you look at this and these
kind of ideas this is very scary after
something like who 88 queenie for white
is already threatening mate and - and
you have to really be an extremely
well-versed defender to hold this
position together this is very difficult
in particular in a practical game in
analytically like might still not be
lost but it's very very difficult to
play this as you have no coordination so
this move B form is a very interesting
idea and probably leads to some sizable
advantage if black goes back to the 8th
instead of grabbing this then 94 is a
very annoying idea trying to put the
night here and still play d5 at the
right moment as we see like does not
have enough control over the d5 square
here so white will manage this sum this
pawn push and he should rather be
ready for it in the game wise did not
play before I think it's not easy to see
this move because you might simply not
consider it if you yeah if you are told
ok look at before what do you think of
it then you probably figure it out even
a very strong GM like a ref did not see
it
so array of played d5 this moves look
looks perfectly reasonable though why it
takes bishop takes and here we seem that
blacks set up is a little bit uh
pneumonias a little bit but still enough
you hold this position together in the
theoretical section we recommended a
setup with this rook being here on d8
and the bishops on f88 which is kind of
a back rank formation but it's
completely safe our King position is
safe and I don't think black has any
problems here YUM after this d5 push
like is also ok but it's a little bit
awkward yeah rook 88 it makes sense
cover the bishop here means before and
now black does not have this comfortable
cover with bishop eh obviously he has to
go to f8 still it's not a big deal
because what we have to see him is that
black has no particular yeah weakness
they are long-term weakness why this has
a temporary activity here with the Queen
and Bishop but if we are able to to
cover everything then we should be fine
in particular trading one or two minor
pieces and easily need to a comfortable
position for black we have the bishop
pair after all so white played a ruby 3
yeah this is preparing before this was a
free preview of our entire one d4 course
based on the nimzo-indian and rogozin
available on chess about calm thanks for
watching and see you soon
[Music]